(lively music)
- Steak.
- Oh, close.
So close.
- Lamb.
- I mean, it's kind of the same, right?
It's just like a baby steak.
(lively music)
Oh, dang it, you're allergic to nuts.
- I'm allergic to nuts.
I can't eat 'em.
I mean, they could kill me.
- Yeah, but I've never
seen you put a piece
of lettuce in your mouth
ever, not once in 12 years.
- What's lettuce got for me?
(lively music)
Glass of wine and some TV.
- Oh my gosh, that's pretty close.
I mean, that's--
- A book and some hot tea.
What are you, a hobbit?
(Keegan laughs)
This is unbelievable.
I have you at--
- Actually, actually, actually,
I'm wrong about my own
thing and he's right.
(lively music)
- Dinner out, Chinese.
- I hear a dinner of candy
with his wife and his dog slash son.
(lively music)
- Icon.
Psychopath.
- Right, right, but it's
the best kind of psychopath.
Like you don't have to hang
out with him all the time.
Right, right, right.
Right, exactly.
- Kind of.
Mozart.
- That's the same answer.
- Same answer.
- That is the same answer.
- That's a point.
(lively music)
- This has got to be right.
This has got to be right.
- All right.
Wordness to the turdness.
- (laughs) Yes, I knew it (laughs).
- All right.
Well done.
(Keegan laughs)
We got it, wordness to the turdness.
- Wordness to the turdness.
- It's in the movie.
We've used it in the film.
- It's definitely in the movie.
I didn't really hear it so much as I read.
- He was always doing
fart jokes at parties.
- Exactly, yeah, he was.
Yeah, he was out of his bloody mind.